على كل انسان الناس في مصر الى اي مدى
تؤثر السياسه على كره القدم اسمعها لك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
رياضه ممكن تقرب كثير بين الشعوب
وتدي رساله كويسه للسياسه يعني زي ما شفنا
مثلا همم مقابله السيسي مع اردوغان اا
تصفيه الخلافات ما بين السعوديه وقطر
فمجرد مناسبه عالميه همم يجتمعوا فيها
فممكن تذوب همم
الاثار الجانبيه لاي علاقه سياسيه والامور
ديت يعني لو ما فيش مصالح مشتركه بين
الدول دي بعدين
هيبقى التاثير اكبر انما لو في علاقات
التاثير ممكن يبقى طبيب اصلا ومالوش لازمه
زي روسيا مثلا روسيا الان استعملت موضوع
كره القدم سياسيا لسبب دخولها هي و
اوكرانيا في بعض الاحيان بتقرب المسافات
السياسيه او بتزيل الحواجز السياسيه يعني
لا طبعا اكيد مش بتاثر لان احنا تعودنا من
من الطفوله ان رابط التشجيع للفريق المحب
عمره ما كان يختلط بالسياسه عمري ما كان
مثلا همم الرئيس ده رئيس النادي ده يبقى
في الحزب ده او بيتعمل السياسه دي الكوره
شيء والسياسه شئ ثاني اللي انا شايفه ان
السياسه بيتراعي وبتصرف ملايين الدولارات
على اللاعيبه بحيث ان يبقى عندهم رياضه
وفي نفسي وفي اجياد بتطلع للكوره النهارده
هاشوفوا الاهلي شوفوا الفرقه الكبيره همم
ريال مدريد اسبانيا اللي هي الفرق برشلونه
الفرقه دي دلوقت بتعمل اقتصاد في السياسه
والشغل عالي جدا النهار ده النهار ده فعلا
ده حقيقه الكوره بقت تعتبر سياسه